ciao ragazzi allora benvenuti a questo
video sono orgogliosissimo di
presentarvi questo video maledizione
questa è la cosa più bella che mi sia
successa negli ultimi anni x1 che twigg
ok ed è successa in un momento in cui
non stavo registrando ovviamente prima
di farvi vedere il video vi racconto
cosa è successo eravamo io e ciccio
merlino che stava esattamente qua era un
po che non giocavamo rockets league
insieme che lui è anche molto bravo ha
preso detto giochiamo insieme ci siamo
messi a giocare online
2 contro 2 io in squadra con lui a un
certo punto durante una partita
competitiva inizia la partita e lo
chiama la sua ragazza tutti gli uomini
veri che esistono rispondono alla
ragazza che lasciano tutto voi sta
facendo e corrono a rispondere a dati
hsdpa e normale mi fa scusa scusa però
io eh vabbè dai fa niente
fa niente da io me la gioco ma vabbé
sono uno contro due online e tra l'altro
questi hanno diamante pio sonora anche
platino questo è ora di diamante quindi
un run che ancora più avanti io 1 contro
due sono clinicamente non puoi vincere e
soprattutto se poi sono dello stesso
rank ma io mi chiamo fa vj vi faccio
vedere questa partita ragazzi perché vi
prego io ho giocato da solo non sono
forte in realtà la rocket league mib
reputo medio però questa porca vacca
l'ho giocata da solo completamente da
solo e ve la faccio vedere perché è
incredibile le questo ero io contro due
tra l'altro uno si chiamava leone cane
fifone che questo questo riporta a casa
lee dong quando io giove te che ci costa
in porta ma è fermo tra un po si
disconnette perché offline quindi loro
non mettono proprio tra l'altro io
quando mi capita di rimanere da solo
contro le persone online che poi ha
fatto una cagata allucinante quando mi
capita di essere da solo con delle
persone online
cerco sempre di giocarmela anche se non
ho speranze perché è impossibile
e come se a calcio si giocasse a calcio
a 11 si giocasse
6 contro undici non puoi vincere perché
è strana come cosa però non hai
abbastanza tempo per fare tutto quello
che devi fare è pure eppure successe
qualcosa di vero veramente incredibile
adesso io non so spiegarmi il motivo di
tutto ciò però la partita però sono
effettivamente giocata poi passato già
un minuto e mezzo infatti qua preso cosa
la partenza era negativa però non avevo
aspettative ce ne sensi non è che
giocavo per vincere dice vabbè
chissenefrega tanto lo so che pensano
contro due persone almeno gliela faccio
almeno mi diverto maggio kikkio mi
diverto ma non potrò mai vincere fatte
all'inizio per gusto gol e poi ne
prenderò anche un altro ma so che
sveleranno che gli stili chissenefrega
da qui inizia a diventare gesù non so
per quale motivo in realtà già prima
comunque non ha la sta cavando malissimo
per essere uno contro due anche se non
mi stata alla fine ho preso gol perché
ho fatto due cagate allucinanti come
mezza cagata l'hanno fatta loro non
riesco a segnare comunque però da qua
iniziò a fare cose che non saprei
spiegarmi i ragazzi cioè non neanche io
mentre le facevo mi sono reso conto di
quello che stava succedendo cioè
incredibile all'acqua tentò un controllo
con la palla me lo ricordo e lo sbaglio
tantissimo qua due minuti e mezzo siamo
a metà partita e qualcosa mi si accende
non so bene cosa forse la spia della
riserva ma neanche perché non ho la
patente
il val troppo ridere perché in tutto
questo ragazzi voi non lo sentite ma
c'era ciccio merlino che era al telefono
tratto mano anche bamba man mano che bam
pato non barbato barbato ma battono per
fortuna è meno barban pare vuol dire
quando ti spingono quando vi ha fatto un
controllo
bruttissima e un approfittatore buttata
dentro mi hanno bam pato campare vuol
dire quando non demolisce avversario ma
lo lo spingi per fargli perdere per far
para lontano dalla palla quindi non solo
due contro uno
tanto quando tu bampi un giocatore in
genere colori si incavola quindi quando
lo fai
lo puoi fare quindi non è che scorretto
però è visto male c'è questa cosa che si
è vista mi ha appena fatto è vista male
e quindi puoi farlo cioè sei già due
contro uno cosa infierisce però a
divampavano pure quindi niente qua mi
sento uno di santo 2 ed appunto dentro 2
a 2 un minuto e 38 alla fine da solo si
credibile vabbè qua ho iniziato a dire
ma potrebbe anche non su non succede ma
se succede e che vi sono veramente
impegnato 2 contro 2 2 contro 1 2 a 2
minuti e 30 può succedere di tutto
ragazzi quindi ho iniziato veramente
impegnarmi quale la parata di partenza
di bestia tentò di saltare uno non ci
riesco più attenta al tiro glielo tolgo
me la devo giocare in tutto e per tutto
perché mancava veramente un minuto
ragazzi qua se la butti dentro rischi
vincere perché poi in un minuto poi
effettivamente provare a resistere
quindi che ho detto qua devo veramente
giocarmela come se ne valesse della mia
carriera c'è proprio la roba incredibile
quando avevo il turbo non potevo
dribblarlo però avrei provato a fare
quello poi a tutti e mezzo tentò di
volare mi sa riesco ma il tipo me la
toglie perché ovviamente in due ragazzi
mi piace difende un attacco poi fare
quel che vuole
qua la stoffa ma ne approfitto lo stesso
40 secondi dalla fine tra l'altro siamo
più dalla loro metà campo che dalla mia
la cosa veramente incredibile qua faccio
una cagata colossale
vi prego poi ha fatto una cagata
colossale perché quella potrà essere
dentro invece volevo fare il figo e
tentare di controllarla però non mi
stata brutalmente io ho fatto una cagata
atroce lui mi demolisce qui qua riparto
la missa la ritocco e la metto dentro 3
a 2 sul finale ragazzi 3 a 2 mancano 17
secondi e sono tre a due per me ragazzi
due contro uno due contro uno qua
tentavo di chiuderla perché il tipo lami
stata in partenza ma non sono riuscito e
loro mi hanno fatto il 3 a 3 qua mi sono
giocato la vittoria da solo perché ero
tra due mib a stava a tenere la palla
invece approvato
a fare il 42 all'inizio e loro melan
ficcata dentro perché io essendo da solo
non nessuno che dipende quindi nessuno
me l'ha potuta parare ci fosse stato
ciccio sarebbe stata coperta invece no
quindi io qua mi sono mangiato le mani
perché ero tre aule 32 poteva già essere
finita e invece non è finita ma edizione
quale parolisi hanno traversa riga
traversa riga 3 a 3 supplementari
ragazzi in questo preciso momento torna
a ciccio al 3 a 3 tornato a ciccio è
tornato ciccio e quindi ho avuto questa
speranza alla fine i ragazzi ottenuto
una partita da solo fino alla fine e
tanto solo pure vincendo sul finale
proprio presa avviso ho preso un gol
perché non c'era ci importa ma ragazzi
io veramente ho ottenuto una partita da
solo
se questi sono ragazzi questi sono
diamante cioè non so io sono platino
sono anche meno di loro
qui perché ci c'era anche più avanti
nemmeno perché a ciccio locali alla
gente ma chi se ne frega ti voglio bene
cicciano non è vero e forte ciccio però
porca vacca sono anche superiori al mio
questi verrà qua c'è io sono riuscito a
fare delle robe
non so cosa mi è breve lo giuro non lo
so che si trovi giuro erano anche
diamante adesso non si vede la tabella
perché purtroppo questo non replay tra
l'altro non c'era shatner replay porca
vacca perché nella chat
non so se si può attivare lasciarti in
qualche modo perché vedo ma non penso
perché nel replay la chat e non rimane
però questi qua io ve lo giuro ragazzi
ve lo giuro che non si può attivare
purtroppo lasciate ma questi qua erano
rancidi amanti io sono platino viene
anche prima e mi hanno scritto in chat
six moore che in slang videoludiche è un
mezzo distrutto per dire smurf sarebbe
tipo uno che sa giocare e che arranca
altissimi e si fa un account di livello
più basso per giocare con i novellini
per stracciarli ok quindi mi hanno preso
per uno di questi in realtà non era un
errore anche prima cervello proprio
scarso di loro che io non so come ho
fatto finisce sta partita incredibile
grazie a dio era subentrato poi anche
ciccio però viene sul finale io stavo 3
a 2 per me mancavano 17 secondi io non
so come ho fatto a fare questa cosa non
lo so io vi giuro
oddio che non so come ho fatto a vincere
sta partita allucinante comunque ho
salvato subito reti quando è tornato
ciccio mi fanno scusa però mi dispiace
di farci show guarda al risultato ti
prego riguarda 3 a 3
corro ha preso il joystick abbia
iniziato a giocare poi quattro a tre
ragazzi pazzesco cioè io da solo
ottenuto ottimi avversari ho fatto anche
degli errori pensate sono avessi fatto
perché lo missata due o tre volte da tre
ma i polsi per quanto brutta l'azione
che ho fatto però il resto me la sono
giocata a caso erano in due
bellissimo cioè questa è stata una delle
più belle partite che ho fatto non la
più bella la più bella la feci in live
di core nei tempi quando a un 2 a 0 per
gli avversari ho fatto 3 2 negli ultimi
30 secondi però ero in coppia o pietro
vi parlano da ben comunque bella partita
volevo documentare vela e farvela vedere
lasciarvela via la traversata questo
video non l'ho fatto tanto per voi ho
fatto per me per tenerla lì della serie
una volta che ho vinto 4 a 3 con quelli
giocando da solo
tranne sul finale più avanti vari
guarderò ed il ok quella volta in cui
vinsi me e me la ricorderò perché quindi
questo video era un po per me non per
voi però guardatevelo chi sembra che
questo era un video tanto per ma volevo
farvela vedere perché meritava la vita
bellissima sembrati anche dieci minuti
quindi stomps fantastico spero che vi
sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale 43
dei ragazzi più di così un bacino ci
diamo prossimo video e la ragazza
[Musica]